مستمرون امامكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه بالاوضاع التي فرضتها خطوه تمر
ديفاكنر على الدفاع الروسيه
اذا هي لحظه مفاجئه وفارقه تعيشها روسيا
على وقع حرب ضلت احداثها تسيطر على مناخها
السياسي والعسكري طوال ونصف العام تقريبا
جاء تمرد فاغنر ليحرك المشهد يزيده تعقيدا
ويطوي سنوات طويله من العلاقه المتشابكه
لمالك المجموعه المتمرده مع راس السلطه
انقلب بريغوجين على الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وعلى جيشه في خطوه وصفها
سيد الكرملين بطعنه في الظهر وفي سياق هذه
الخطوره تحركات على الارض تبدو وكانها
بحسب مراقبين وعده مسبقا يفتح على بوتين
جبهه داخليه تشتت انتباهه على اقل تقدير
عن عمليته العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا 25
الف عنصر من باجنر مستعدون للموت بحسب
المهم وقائدهم حدد لهم موسكو وجهه لاعداد
كبيره منهم ومعداتهم طريقهم بدا من رستوف
الف كيلو متر جنوب موسكو كانت محطه خساره
اولى للقوات الروسيه مع تاكيد التسليم مقر
قيادتها الاستراتيجي دون مقاومه او اطلاق
رصاصه واحده ومن ثم فارونيج هو عبر طريق
ام 4 والنهايه المطاف موسكو التي استنفرت
الاستعدادات والتعزيزات فيها لصد التمرد
الاتي نحوها بعد تفعيل قانون مكافحه
الارهاب الارتال اربعه بحسب موقع ريبار
العسكري محمله بما يصل الى 400 اليه
عسكريه فاي خطر يحدق بالعاصمه الروسيه وهل
فعلا يعد الموقف حرجا لوريث الجيش الاحمر
ولسيد الكرملين
[موسيقى]
كل المؤشرات كانت تقود الى انفجار الاوضاع
وبالفعل انفجرت روسيا تواجه تمردا مسلحا
وعصيانا وخيانه للشعب من قبل باجنار وبوصف
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
المصالح الشخصيه ادت الى خيانه الوطن
والشعب هذا عصيان لبلدنا والردود على هذه
التصرفات ستكون قاسيه وصارمه
وسيتحملون المسؤوليه والعقاب الذي لا مفر
منه سوف ندافع عن دولتنا ومواطنين من كل
هذه التهديدات والخونه
هو الاخر يرى الامر خيانه لكن خيانه من
ناحيه مختلفه بوجهه نظره وزرته ودفاع
روسيه هي من تحاول خدع بوتين
كنا نتبادل اطلاق النار بتواتر مختلف
واستمر ذلك لثماني سنوات الان تحاول وزاره
الدفاع خداع الرئيس والجمهور واخبارهم
بوجود عدوان شرس من قبل اوكرانيا وانهم
سيهاجموننا مع كتله الناتو باكملها انطلقت
ما تسمى بالعمليه الخاصه في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير لاسباب مختلفه تماما
على كل وزاره الدفاع خائنه بالنسبه
نائب قائد القوات الروسيه في منطقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو شخص مقرب من
بروغوجينا ويمتلكه معه علاقه طيبه لكن
بعدما وصفه بوتين بالعصيان تغير الامر
اتوجه بنداء الى قائد فاجنر وعناصره لقد
مررنا معا بطريق صعب قتلنا معا وتكبدنا
الخسائر معا ثم انتصرنا معا نحن دم واحد
لذا انا ادعو الى التوقف حالا فالعدو
ينتظر ان يدخل بلدنا ازمه داخليه ولا يجب
ان نضع يدنا في يد العدو في هذا الوقت
الصعب اوقفوا القافله وعودوا الى مواقع
انتشاركم
اليهم من احاديث واختلاف وجهه نظر كل طرف
المحصله واحده روسيا امام خطر حرب اهليه
لكن من الرابح من كل هذا يبدو انها
اوكرانيا عليها ان تستغل الفرصه وتحرر
اراضيها لندن تخبر كييف بذلك
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق ما كنا نتحدث عنه من فرصه
لاوكرانيا مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
يقول ان تمرد فاغنر فرصه جيده وسنستغلها
اذا يقول المستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان تمرد فيغنار فرصه جيده
وسنستغلها يعني معنى من موسكو مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشته اهلا بك عبد
الجواد ما هي اخر التطورات بما يتعلق
بالارتال العسكريه المتحركه لفاجنر الى
موسكو وكيف تبدو الاستعدادات في العاصمه
الروسيه لها
في البدايه مساء الخير روحانيين حتى هذه
اللحظه اخر اعلانات مؤسس مجموعه فاقنر
وقائدها
كانت بان قواته دخلت منذ نحو ساعه ونصف من
الان الضواحي العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
توقعات بان الساعات القليله القادمه ستشهد
وصول هذه القوات وهذه الارتال العسكريه
الى مركز المدينه او ضواحي او مشارفها
طبعا حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت اعداد هذه
القوافل سريه نوعا ما يدور الحديث عن
تقارير بان هذه الاعداد تصل الى 5000 لكن
هذا الرقم حسب القراءه التحليليه في
البلاد هو مبالغ به نوعا ما فخمسه الاف
جندي دعا يحتاجون يعني عشره قطارات لنقلهم
بشكل كبير وسريع نحو مركز المدينه التي
تحركهم عبر القوافل العسكريه فهم بيحتاجون
الى مئات المعدات الاليات العسكريه للوصول
لكن ما تم نشره هو خرابط يتراوح ما بين
خمسه عشر الى عشرين اليه عسكريه تتحرك على
يعني فرق مختلفه وهذه مقاطع الفيديو تظهر
من شوارع مختلفه على الطريق الواصل بين
رستوف ومدينه موسكو حتى هذه اللحظه موسكو
تقوم بالتجديد الامني بما يخص المدينه
يعني حاكم المدينه صبيان يتحدث عن تجديد
الاجراءات الامنيه في البدايه قام باعطاء
يوم الاثنين القادم بعد الغد واعلنه يوم
عطله رسمي لكافه يعني سكان المدينه
باستثناء من يعمل في القوات وفي الحمايه
والشرطه وغيرها ووسائل الدوله بالاضافه
الى ان طبعا قام صبيان بدعوه اهالي
المدينه الى عدم الخروج في نزهات خلال
الوضع الامني غير المستقر الان في هذا
الوضع تحدث عن ضروره الالتزام في المنا
والابتعاد عن يعني ما يسمى الاماكن التي
قد يتجمع فيها الكثير من الناس حنين
عبد الجواد كان هناك تاكيدات عن نشر
تعزيزات وايضا مدافع رشاشه على مداخل وعلى
مشارف العاصمه موسكو كيف وصلت الارتال
وتجاوزت هذه النقطه تتحدث عن وقت قصير جدا
لبلوغها الى مركز العاصمه
نعم يعني مشارف المدينه حنين يعني تبعد عن
مركز المدينه قرابه الاربعين الى خمسين
كيلومترا اذا ما تم الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
نصف قطر المدينه لذلك ارطالب لم تصل حتى
هذه اللحظه الى المداخل وعليها في البدايه
المرور عبر يعني منطقه كشيرسكا والتي
تتجمع فيها اعداد كبيره من القوات الروسيه
لمراقبه الوضع قد لا يحدث صدام بين هذه
القوات لكن كما هو ملاحظه بان هذه القوات
موجوده هناك يعني للوقوف على النقاط
الامنيه قامت موسكو طبعا باغلاق الكثير من
الشوارع خارج حدود المدينه وضعت الكثير من
نقاط التفتيش على مداخل المدينه وهدا على
ما يبدو عبد الجواد ايضا يحدث
لهذا العاجل اسفل الشاشه كان قبل قليل
يؤكد حاكم روستوفا بتقي يد الدخول الى
المدينه مدينه رستوب اذن ما هي اخر
المعلومات حول المتوفره لديك حول اكثر من
منطقه
تنتشر فيها باجنر حاليا مع القوات الروسيه
وتحديدا عن ايضا القوات الشيشانيه التي
وصلت الى روستوب عبد الجواد
حنين يعني قوات فاغنر عبرت من دانيت نحو
مقاطعه راس طوب في تلك المنطقه من مقاطع
الفيديو التي ترد الان في العواجل ومن
الاخبار نلاحظ تواجد لقوات فاجنر في شوارع
مدينه يعني منذ قليل شاهدنا مقطع فيديو
يتم فيه اطلاق رصاص خمس عينات تم اطلاقها
لتفرقه الناس المجتمعين تم اطلاقها في
الهواء الطلق لكن حتى هذه اللحظه الصدام
المباشر بين قوات رمضان قاديره وقوات لم
يحدث بعض والكثير من الاراء السياسيه في
البلاد تتحدد بان هذا الصدام قد لا يحدث
اذا توصلت حكومه البلاد مع ايفرجن لحل
لهذا الموضوع طبعا قافله مرت عبر العديد
من القاليم ابرزها هي هو اقليم فارونج
طبعا هناك حسب روايه حاولت الدفاع الروسيه
ضرب هذه الارتال لكن خرج وتحدث القاتله
تمكنوا من اسقاط الست مروحيات وطائره نقل
عسكريه من طرازئيل ثمانيه عشر هذا ما نشره
ونشر صور تظهر حطام قط للمروحيه من طراسكا
اثنان وخمسون حسب روايه
هي النقطه الساخنه كانت في فارونج وفي
ضواحيها هناك طبعا هناك نقطه اخيره لو
سمحت لي هناك تم ضرب يعني مصفاه لتكرير
النفط لعدم التزود بالوقود من هناك
وتصاعدت السلسله النهار الى سماء المقاطعه
هنا شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الجواد الرشد
العربيه
اعلنت اوكرانيا قبل قليل لانها احرزت
تقدما في عده مناطق على الجبهات خلال
هجومها المضاد ونحن نتابع معكم الان
الكلمه
يتحدث عن هذا الامر وعن تمرد فيغنار واكد
كما نتابع معكم في العاجل اسفل الشاشه ان
بوتين قد غادر موسكو اذا هو يوجه رساله
باللغه الروسيه للروس ولم يتحدث لا يتحدث
الان في الاوكرانيه يقول انه كلما طال
بقاء بوتين ستزداد الخسائر اذا هذه
التصريحات من الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي
يوجه رساله باللغه الروسيه للروس وليس
بالاوكرانيه يقول فيها انه كلما طال بقاء
بوتا ستزداد الخسائر كانت ايضا كيافه
تحدثت عن تقدم في الجبهه الشرقيه في
اوكرانيا مع هذا التمرد لفاجنر على الدفاع
الروسيه وعلى الكرملين اذا مشاهدينا ما
اسباب هذا العصيان كما وصفه وابوتا او
التمرد على حد وصف او الانقلاب
بحسبور الغاضب يقول ان قائد هيئه الاركان
بليرزن اعطى الاوامر بقصف المعسكرات
الخلفيه لمجموعه فاغنر ثم توجه بريغوجوشن
بسؤال
وزير الدفاع
هرب الان بجبن من رستوف هرب بجبن كالنساء
ليتهرب من الاجابه عن سؤال لماذا قصفت
المروحيات الروسيه عناصرنا
قائد هيئه الاركان الاوامر بانطلاق
الطائرات وضربها القوافل التي تعبر بين
السيارات المدنيه والشاحنات لا يهمه من
سيقتل فهم امض عاما ونصف العام بقتل
مواطنيهم المدنيين المسالمين بدلا من
محاربه العدو واود ان اشكر الطيارين الذين
رفضوا المتول لهذه الاوامر الاجراميه
على هذا الاتهام من قبل قائد فاجنر وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه نفت الامر واشارت الى انها
لا تتوافق مع الواقع ووصفتها
بالاستفزاز الاعلامي على كل كل المقاطع
المصوره من مدينه روستوب الحقها بالتاكيد
بان مقر القياده الروسيه سلم لفاجنر دون
اي مقاومه
[موسيقى]
نحن داخل مقر الجيش في الساعه السابعه
والنصف صباحا المواقع العسكريه في رستوف
بما في ذلك المطار تحت السيطره
التوتر في رستوف اذا ولذلك دعا حاكم
المنطقه السكان الى ملازمه منازلهم لانهاء
هذا النزاع دعوه قائد لقواته من اجل
التمرد قابلها بيان من الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي لمقاتلي المجموعه عليكم الصيام
الاوامر الاجراميه الوضع يخرج عن السيطره
اذا وبوتين يتجه لاتخاذ اجراءات صارمه
وقاسيه تعهد بسحق التمرد
اجراءات صارمه وقاسيه لاستقرار الوضع في
مقاطعه روستو وكمواطن ورئيس روسيا سافعل
كل ما في وسع للدفاع عن روسيا واستقلالها
وحريه مواطنيها ومن نظم وحضر هذا التمرد
المسلح سيتحمل المسؤوليه الكامله ومن تم
جره الى هذه الجريمه ادعوكم الى الالتزام
بالتعقل والعوده الى الوطن ووقف هذه
التصرفات
تعهد بوتين اذا بسحق التمرد هي خيانه
وطعنه جاءت من الظهر بحسب وصفه لكن هل
يمكن ان يسامح بوتا في الخيانه دعونا نعود
بالزمن قليلا الى الوراء لنعرف الاجابه
[موسيقى]
يتبادر هذا السؤال للكثيرين لماذا رستوف
تحديدا التي بدات قوه بالسيطره عليها
الاسباب كثيره اولها ان روستوف هي احدى
احدى اكبر المدن الروسيه قربها من الحدود
الاوكرانيه جعلها نقطه استراتيجيه في
امداد الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا سبب اخر
هو ان المدينه تمثل اهميه استراتيجيه
للجيش الروسي فهي مقر قياده المنطقه
العسكريه الجنوبيه فيها مطار عسكري يقلع
منه الطيران الروسي لضربي اهداف داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه نظرا لقربها من
اوكرانيا واقليمي
المدينه تحتوي على منصات او قواعد
الصواريخ وقد تشكل خطرا كبيرا وتهديدا
اكبر اذا ما استولت عليها قوه باك نار الى
ذلك روستوبا تعتبر اقرب نقطه على بحر ازوف
للداخل الروسي وموسكو وفيها ميناء له كثير
من الاهميه كخط امداد للقوات الروسيه على
طول سواح ل بحر ازوف في لوغانس والجنوب
الاوكراني وشبه جزيره القرم هذا التهديد
يعني قطع الامداد عن القوات الروسيه
المقاتله على طول الجبهه في اوكرانيا
مشاهدينا ايضا ان ننوه لهذا العاجل رئيس
بيلاروسيا يقول ان قائد فاجنر وافق على
وقف تقدم قواته نحو موسكو اذا هذا تطور
خطير وواضح الرئاسه البيلاروسيه رئيس
بيلاروسيا يؤكد ان قائد فاجنر وافق على
وقف زحف قواته وارتالها الى قلب العاصمه
موسكو ايضا الرئاسه البلوروسيه تقول هناك
اقتراح مقبول بضمانات امنيه لمقاتلي
فاغنار لوقفه القتال اذا بعد هذا اليوم
الليله التي تطورت فيها الاحداث بشكل كبير
مع قوات فيغنار اعلان بريغوجين رئيس وقائد
قوات افاكنار التمرد على الدفاع الروسيه
وعلى الكرملين تاتي الان هذه التصريحات من
رئيس بيلاروسيا يتحدث عن موافقه بروجين
على وقفه زحف قواته باتجاه
ويتحدث ايضا عن اقتراح مقبول بضمانات
امنيه لمقاتله فاجنر لوقف القتال اذا كانت
كل الاحداثيات تتحدث عن وصول ارتال فاغنار
الى مشارف العاصمه موسكو وعن وقت قصير قبل
بلوغها الى مركز العاصمه موسكو ايضا هناك
الكثير من المعدات والاليات العسكريه
تحملها هذه الارتال بحسب تقارير اعلاميه
عسكريه تحدثا عن اكثر من 250
الف
اليه عسكريه اذا وهي اربعه ارتال عسكريه
تحمل جنود او عناصر لفاجنر مع معدات
عسكريه
لا اعرف على ايه حاله القوات المسلحه في
المدينه سيئه لا ينبغي ان يكون هناك
عسكريون او مسلحون في المدينه
لا اعتقد انهم استولوا على المدينه اعتقد
ان نوعا من المفاوضات سيجري وان السلطاتنا
ستتخذ جميع الاجراءات اللازمه
قبل بيان الرئاسه البيلاروسيه
تحدث عن رغبته في دخول موسكو حينما دخل
اليوم مدينه رستوف توسط جلسه بين نائبين
لوزير الدفاع الروسي لكن كان لديه هدف اخر
من هذا الحديث
هنا في مدينه روستوف ونحن نريد قائد
الاركان
قبل ان يهرب طبعا في انتظار ذلك سنبقى هنا
في ارسطوف وفي الوقت نفسه سنتجه الى موسكو
من موسكو وينضم الينا
المحلل العسكريه الروسيه اهلا بك سابدا
معك من هذا التطور ما تحدثت به الرئاسه
البيلاروسيه ورئيس بيلاروسيا تحدث عن
وساطه تجري حاليا مع فيجنر مع بروجن لتوقف
ووقف زحف قوته نحو العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
السلام عليكم
هذه الاخبار الاخيره بشان
وساطه الرئيس الباروسي
وموافقه على وقف تقدم قواته نحو موسكو على
دليل على ان استوعب انه غير قادر على دخول
العاصمه موسكو
رغم
التقدم السريع جدا يعني من صباح اليوم
تمكنت ارتيل جماعه فاغنر من قطع مسافه
حوالي 7
كيلو متر من رستوف وحتى موسكو
نعم هناك اكثر من شويه اكثر من الف كيلو
متر ولكن
الان
ارتمام
دخلت محافظه
موسكو
بعد عبور محافظه واروج ولبسك
التطور مؤلم ومؤسف
فات اللغه العربيه غنيه جدا وماليه
بالكلمات والمرادفات والمصطلحات والى اخره
لا ادري لماذا
وسائل الاعلام اتفقت على تسميه الاحداث
هذه التمرد هو ذكرها كتمرد في البدايه سيد
ششكوب
خيانه واضحه لان
سحب القوات وهي احسن تدريبا مقاتلون جماعه
لهم خبره قتاليه سحب اكثر من 25 الف
بالمقاتلين من ضوء الخبره العسكريه
والقتاليه ومعهم دبابات 90 ونقلات مدرعه
حديثه والى اخره وارسالها على الطريقه
السريع الى موسكو تحت الشراء الشعار
مكافحه الفساد والبيروقراطيه وفي الوقت
عندما تستعيد
للمرحله الثانيه يعني عندما تلك القوات
لها حاجه مس في هذا القتايل هذا احلى هديه
لاعلى روسيا
جدا وهذا مقالته بيلاروسيا وهي ايضا الان
تقول ان هناك ضمانات قدمت لهذه في هذه
الوساطه ما يمكن ان يكون شكل هذه الضمانات
لا اعتقد ان هناك اي ضمان شخصي لرئيس
لانه
اجتاز كل الخطوط الحمر
عندما كان هناك خلاف شخصي بينه وزير
الدفاع ورئيس اركان الجيش جلال جيش
يعني اعتبر ذلك كاشيه شخصي حتى ولو خارج
من النطاق المسموح به من جميع النواحي
انسانيا واعلاميا وعسكريا والى خريه
من ثم
ايضا
الاتهامات من قبل
هجوم على مؤخرات
هذا الماسكات الخلفيه لخضر لا هناك اي
دليل لا هناك اي برهان
يقول انه قبل مقترح من بيلاروسيا لوقف
تقدم قواته نحو موسكو اذا يؤكد قائد فاغن
عن قبوله مقترح من بيلاروسيا لوقت تقدم
قوته نحو
استوعب لا فرصه له
لاكمال هذه المهمه انه الامدادات مقطوعه
ودعم اللوجيسي مقطوع
والجيش النظامي
يتحشد في تلك المنطقه
الموضوع الان هو
الضمانات لمنتسبي جماعه بغداد حتى له تم
اسكتس ست مروحيات روسيه بما فيها احلى
موديل قام في 52 والطاقم مستشده
الى ما يريده بريكوشن ماذا يريد بالضبط
يعني هو يقول هو يريد غراسي موف ويريد
شايكو ولكن ماذا يريد من الرئيس بوتين
هو يريد اكثر من ذلك نعم عندما يقول صاحب
شركه امنيه خاصه يعني سحب الاعمال
يريد وزير الدفاع للدوله النوويه ويا ريت
رئيس هيئه الاركان للجيش لدوله العظمى ومن
ثم يريد التوصل الى صوته ويقول انه هذه
الفئه الفاسده التي تحكم في موسكو لازم
تنشل ولاخره يعني هذا الاعتداء على الدوله
هذا محاوله الانقلاب العسكري هذا التحدي
على الرئيس بوتين شخصيا
اعتقد المصير السيد
مصير اسود
اعتقد انه يعود الى سجن حيث
كان سنوات طويله في السابق حكم عليه
بالسجن في السابق مرتين على ارتكاب
الجرائب الجنائيه وهو متاكد ومتعوده على
الحياه في سجن فهذا هو مصير واعتقد نعم
فلتتفضل لابي البقاء معنا ضمن سياق هذه
التغطيه اذا لماذا تدهورت العلاقه بين
قائد فاغنار
والرئيس الروسيه بوتين التاثير الاساسي
كان بسبب المعارك التي كانت دائره في
بخموت قبل اشهر قبل السيطره الكامله على
المدينه اتصل بريجوجل ببوتين قبل اشهر
لاول مره ليشكي له نقص الذخيره اتصال جاء
بعدما باتت العلاقه مع الجنرالات الروس في
حكم المنتهيه وتحديدا وزير الدفاع صربيا
شويغو وقائد الاركان
بالخيانه وبخداع الرئيسي لكن ربما في هذه
الاتهامات ما طال صديقه وقتها بوتا
[موسيقى]
شيبو
سني غيرني صلب
[موسيقى]
من قصد قائد باجنر بالعجوز المحظوظه في
ذلك الوقت بعض الخبراء رجحوا ان اللفظه
كان وقتها اشاره لبوتا تدهورت العلاقه
كثيرا وسنعود لنقطه مفصليه في هذا التدهور
نحن في العام 2022 قبل عام فقط جلب مجموعه
فاجنر بعد هزيمه قاسيه في الربيع لتدخل
مجموعه الى معركه باخموت لكن شهيه
السياسيه هي من حولت البوصله شعر الكريم
ان قائد فاجنر لديه طموحات اكبر كان يحاول
الاستفاده من الحرب والحصول على مكاسب
سياسيه واقتصاديه قاد عده
كانوا خائفين ويعتقدون انه يمثل تهديدا
للدوله بحسب شركه ابلتكس وهي شركه متخصصه
في تحليل السياسات الروسيه هنا استمع
بوتين للشكاوى وحاول تقليل نفوذ بريكوشن
في قرار بوتين في اواخر العام الماضي
باعاده دراسه
اخرين للواجهه في الحرب الاوكرانيه وهم
المشتبكين اصلا مع بريجوجن وصل الامر
لدرجه منعه من تجنيد المسجونين في باجنر
وهو الذي كان مسموحا له بذلك قد يكون
الطموح السياسي اوقف زحف لكن يبدو ان
نجاحاته من احبته شعبيه كبيره ماذا لو
اجريت انتخابات روسيه في اقرب وقت ممكن
لمن سيصوت الروس استطلاع الروسي قبل شهر
تقريبا اجراه مركز
فيه على
39.7% بينما حصل بوتين على
42.5% الفارق بسيط
اذا بالمنطق العسكري وبحسب عدد من
المحللين العسكريين لم يعد الجيش الروسي
بحاجه الى فيغنر خصوصا بعدما سيطرت
المجموعه على بخمه قبل اشهر مقاتلوها باتو
مرهقين معنوياتهم منخفضه وقتها حاول تقويه
المجموعه مؤخرا ظهرت تقارير تتحدث عن
انضمام الجنرال الرومان
نائب القائد السابق للحرس الوطني الروسي
والجنرال ميخائيل نائب وزير الدفاع السابق
الى فيغنر بعد اقالتهما من الخدمه المدنيه
هذه التقارير ربما كانت مقدمه لاستيلاء
الكرملين على باجنر بحسب افلاد مكانكم
الخبير في الشؤون الروسيه فكره اخرى كانت
تشغل الراي
وتقلق الجميع حتى انه انتقد الكرملين علنا
بسببها انشاء شركات عسكريه خاصه جديده
بدلا من
وننوه لهذا العاجل على الشاشه يقول لحقن
الدماء نعلن التراجع من جهه واحده والعوده
الى مراكزنا اذا يقول قائد فاجنر انه لحقن
دماء نعلن التراجع من جهه واحده
والعوده الى مراكزنا اذا واعود الى ضيفنا
سيد
المحلل العسكري الروسي هذا التصريح من
قائد فاجنر يتحدث عن حقن الدماء سيعود
بذلك للتراجع من جهه واحده والعوده الى
مراكز افاجنر ماذا يعني هذا التصريح
يعني مجرد مناوره اعلاميه وسياسيه لم يهتم
بالدم
فمن صباح اليوم
جماعه بريجين
اسقطت اكبر عدد من السمتيات او المروحيات
الروسيه من
العدد
الذي فقدته القوات الجويه الروسيه في جبهه
القتال مع اوكرانيا من بدايه الشهر يعني
سبعه طيارات في يوم واحد
هذا فضيحه هذا مسخره عار عيب
هنا نقطه مهمه جدا
شركه عسكريه خاصه
مثل شركه
وصاحبها هذا امر غير موجود قانونيا في
روسيا ليست في روسيا قانون
ينص على تشكيل الشركات العسكريه الخاصه
الشركات الامنيه الخاصه نعم
المسموح هذا شيء مسموح به ولكن لا يوجد
قانون شركات عسكريه خاصه
وخمسه عشر قامت بمحلات خارجيه وايضا
موجوده غير قانونيا هذا تنظيم عسكري غير
شرعي مع ذلك تم تزويده وتصليحها
بالدبابات حتى اخر موديل 90
والتيارات القذفات
والرجيمات ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي
واصل عدد المقاتلين في جماعه الى 70 الف
مقاتله على ثلاث في
ركن كامل
فيقول انه هو يمول تلك القوات ويسليحها
على حسابه وهنا يطرح هذا السؤال يعني يعني
الان بهذه اللحظه الفارقه
مكون العسكري في روسيا
يتصارع او يتواجه مع مكون غير معرف لا
يعرف من من ياخذ اوامره بالضبط والان
تحدثت عن نقطه التسليح والتمويل ايضا يعني
من المحتمل ان يكون يعطي
الاوامر ام ان بريجوجل اصبح فوق الامر
اصلا
عن الخلاف
والتبادل بالكلمات شديده اللهجه
والاتهامات الشخصيه من قبل
على وزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه الاركان الجيش
يعني كان هناك كلمات غير مقبوله اطلاقا
ومع ذلك
كان تصليح وتجهيز
ماشي ومتواصلا فهنا سؤال يطرح نفسه يعني
كيف يمكن ان تجهز الصناعه الحربيه الروسيه
تنظيم غير الشرعي باخر انواع الاسلحه
وفي ظل النزاع الشخصي بين ساحب تلك الشركه
وزير الدفاع وزير الدفاع النظامي
الرسمي
وتم تعيينه من قبل رئيس الجمهوريه ثانيا
فيما يخص التمويل
فيلك كامل يعني اكثر من سبعين الف مقاتل
وكل واحد منهم ياخذ راتب شهري اقل لا اكل
من 3000 دولار شهريا وهناك اضافات على
مشاركه في عام القتاليه وهناك اضافات
ومرتبات اخرى
من جيبه فهنا السؤال من اين لك
تاريخ جمعه باقدر ليست اليوم او يومين او
شهرين يعني من 2016 وكانت الجماعه هذه
اجتهدت في ليبيا
وجمهوريه افريقيا
وغيرها
يعني هناك اسئله كثيره
الخبراء اجتماعون في ان الريس بوتين له
جزء كبير في اعاز
الموافقات
لتجهيز تلك
المجموعه باعتبارها
مطلوبه جدا في جبهه القتال حتى
يعني جمع
هؤلاء الذين في في سجون
تم سحبهم من السجود لاملاء وحدات ومن ثم
تم اعفاؤهم هناك شخص واحد فقط في روسيا له
الحق في الاعفاء هو رئيس الجمهوريه على اي
اساس
انا اخذك من السجن وعليك ان تحارب سته
اشهر ثم ترجع الى البيت حتى ولو حكم عليك
25 سنه في السجن
يطرح يطرح التساؤل من اين له كل هذه
الصلاحيات الواسعه وبالتالي يطرح ايضا
التساؤل ماذا يريد بروجن من كل هذا يعني
وايضا هل هو خلاف شخصي مع الشخصيات
الروسيه العسكريه ام انه مدفوع
باجنده خارجيه ام انه يعني لا يمكن ان
تكون هذه مارب سياسيه يحاول تحقيقها بحسب
جميع التحليلات برايك ما هو الدافع
الحقيقي خلف كل هذا التصرف كل ما يريده
الان
هو خروج
المسرح والحفاظ على حياته وخصوصا بعد
تصريح الرئيس بوتين صباح اليوم حيث قال
انه من ارتكب هذه الجرائم هو خائن خائن
الوطن وسوف
يتحاسب بموجب القانون اذا بعد التحليل
اتهمت انه فقد الدعم من قبل الرئيس بوتين
والان
هو لعب دورا
فظيع في خيانه تلوات بالفعل يعني احلى
هديه لعداء روسيا في سوى في داخل البلد او
في ليس بالصدفه الرئيس ذا قال انه يؤيد
جماعه
كل كل تاييد وزير الخ انه كل ما تكثر
المشاكل في روسيا كلما ترتاح اكثر فاكثر
ففي في مثل هذه الظروف الفكره الوحيده
الحاله الوحيد في
راس بريجوجل هو الاستسلام والاستسلام
باسرع ما يمكن
دونوه لهذا العاجل على الشاشه الرئاسه
البيلاروسيه تتحدث وتقول ان المحادثات بين
لوكيتشينكو وقائد فاجنر تمت بموافقه بوتين
اذا الرئاسه البيلاروسيه تقول ان
المحادثات بين لوك تشينكو وقائد فاغنار
تمت بموافقه بوتين اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت
معنا من موسكو
المحلل العسكري الروسي
اكثر من عام على الحرب افلا نجم الكثير
ممن تسيدوا المشهد في روسيا لكن والله
وجهان بارزا يتصارعان على كسب ود بوتين
قائد فاجنر يبقيني بريغوجن وقائد العمليات
رئيس الاركان
الخلاف بينهما يعكس ما يحدث اليوم قصتهما
تعود لسنوات والبدايه كانت في فبراير
برازيموفه وقتها يلقي محاضره عن اسس الحرب
الهجينه نظريته تعارض عقيده الجيش
استوحاها من كتابنا للفيلسوف
النظريه تقوم على مبدا واحد على اربعه
بمعنى ان العمليات العسكريه تمثل ربع
الاستراتيجيه ضد الخصم والبقيه هي تطوير
الاسلحه السيبرانيه تمكين وتمويل المعارضه
والضغط الاقتصادي على العدو لكن بالتركيز
على جزء العمليات العسكريه فالنظريه تتضمن
فكره انضمام ش خاصه للقتال مع الجيش وهذه
النظريه هي التي اوجدت فاغنر الا ان قرارا
اخر اجعلها تخرج عن سيطره جراث الاخير اقر
في 2014 اجراء اصلاحيات هيكليه افقدت
الجيش نصف ضباطه واكثر من 80% من ضباط
الصف الذين رفضوا تجديد عقودهم ذهب اغلبهم
للتقاعد وهنا كان بريجوجن في الانتظار كان
حينها رجل الاعمال بسجل اجرامي دون خبره
عسكريه اسس فاجنر في 2015 فاتحا الباب
للمنبوذين من الجيش وحتى المساجين رواتب
مغريه والحريه مقابل سته اشهر من الخدمه
على الجبهه غضب غرازيموف وبات يكن العداء
البريجوجن اتهمه بشن مغامرات ان نتجه عن
مقتل المواطنين روس في سوريا في دير الزور
وبرز الخلاف الى السطح عندما فشل بريجوجن
بالحصول على عقود حصريه بتموين الجيش في
2018 الجيش الروسي دفع البرلمان نهايه
العام الماضي الى اصدار قانون ينظم عمل
الشركات الخاصه رفض الخطوه وتساءل عن
الهدف من اصلاح كيان يعمل بكفاءه وان
بالقتل المتسلسلين ومن هنا بدا سجال انتهى
بتمرد
[موسيقى]
جبهه اخرى فعقدها بريكو جنائي باعلانه
التمرد جبهه الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قادروف
لا مبرر لذلك هكذا تحدث قاديروف معلنا
دعمه لبوتين مضيفا ان القوات الشيشانيه
غادرت الى مناطق التوتر رفقه القوات
الروسيه
محارب منذ ولادته ومقاتلي باجنر وطنيون
وشجعان هكذا اشاد رئيس الشيشاني رمضان
قدروفبي في نوفمبر العام الماضي عندما
انتقد الطرفان الدفاع الروسيه لتعاملها مع
قوات كل منهما لكن خلافا اخر لكن خلافا
اخر مع صديقي الامس يقوده بريغوجن ظاهره
الخلاف الى العلن انتقد اعلان قادره
بالنشر كتيبه احمد الشيشانيه في اقليم
دومباس والرد جاء على لسان حليف قدروف ادم
الدين
كنت لا تفهم دوره كتيبه احمد في الخطوط
الاماميه فبسعه كان تتواصل معنا في اي وقت
قل لنا متى واين وسنراك سنحل مشاكلنا وجها
لوجه
بعدها انتقد قادره اللجوء الى مقاطع فيديو
لحل ازمه نقص الذخيره داعيا لحل الخلاف
بين باجنر والدفاع الروسيه ليرد زعيمر
بانه لم يخطئ بالتعليق على تقييمه لقدرات
القوات الشيشانيه
ومن موسكو تنضم الينا سبنينا المستشار
السياسيه في مركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا
بك اذا هذه الخطوه التمرد الذي اتراجع عنه
الان بواساطه بيلاروسيه كما تحدثت الرئاسه
البيلاروسيه مقابل ضمانات اذا بدانا من
البدايه هل كانت خطوه وليده الهجوم الذي
استهدف قوته في الليله الماضيه ام انه كان
معد مسبقا بحسب ما يتوقع ويقول الكثيرون
وعلى راسهم
مساء الخير هي ان لم تكن ولدت الهجوم لان
اصلا ليست هناك تاكيدات انه صار هجوم
عليهم من قبل القوات الروسيه فما يقوله
ويصرع بعد الاحيان بعيده عن الحقيقه في
بعض الاحيان هناك جزء من حقائق ولكن حول
هذا الهجوم لا توجد تاكيدات
حتى لا توجد تاكيدات من قبل المراسلين
عسكريين موجودين هناك في تلك الاماكن ولكن
هي ايضا ليست محاوله الانقلاب برايي رغم
انه الرئيس السابق سيد
فيتكلم عن هذا الشيء وهو ايضا
يدعي بانه هناك
صله
بعناصر اجنبيه ودوليه بين سيد
هذه العناصر وما يحدث فانا ايضا اشك في
هذه النظريه
في تصريحات
ايضا توجد نقطه مغلقه للغايه هو يقول
يمكن للعالم ان نتصوروا اذا حصل السجناء
سابقين على الاسلحه النوويه فبعتقد انه هو
ذهب للبعيد في مثل هذه التصريحات على كل
ان ما يحدث هي وليده خلافات ما بين
ووزير الدفاع هو رئيس الاركان وهناك اشياء
ملموسه ملموسه ولكن
الانسجال هل يمكن للسجال يعني كان يغذيه
بريكوجين بوسائل اعلاميه صحيح كان خلفها
الكثير من المطالب حين طالب بالذخيره
اثناء معركه باخموند ولكن هل يمكن لهذا
الخلاف على تكتيكات او على امدادات عسكريه
ان تتطور لتمرد
والزحفه بات موسكو تهديد لمركز العاصمه
وايضا تحدي للرئيس بوتين شخصيا
بشكل منطقي لا ولكن
في تصرف سيد يوجد نوع كبير من الجنونيه
ولكنه شعر بان ممكن ان يتم القضاء على
شركه على شركته باساليب قانونيه لانه من
اول يوليو كان من المفروض ان يوقع عقدا مع
وزاره الدفاع وحسب هذا العقد على شركه
فاجنر كان ان تندمج بقوات روسيا المصلحه
وبهذا الشكل
كان ممكن ان يفقد بعض صلاحياته هو اكثر
شيء هو كان ممكن ان يفقد عقودا مهما مهمه
حقها مليارات روبل او ملايين دولارات
فاعتقد انه اذا كان هناك حديث حول
مليون دولار او اكثر فهذا ممكن ان يثير
غضب لدى رجل كان لانه مثلا كان هناك مشاكل
حول رغبه
بالقيام بعمليه اتصال مواد غذائيه الجيش
فهذه العقود هي سمينه جدا
ورائها مصالح متعدده
اذا تحدثنا يعني بالنظر الى 24 ساعه
الماضيه وما حدث وما اتخذه بريجوجن ويعني
مجموعه فاجنر من خطوات في المشهد الروسي
ما هي المعادله الجديده بعد التراجع ان تم
هذا التراجع بالفعل ما هي المعادله
الجديده التي ستكون فيها فاجنر مع الحرب
الروسيه ونحن الاوكرانيه ونحن نعرف انها
شكلت يعني قوه مهمه للجيش
الروسي في هذه الحرب حتى الان او العمليه
العسكريه كيف سيكون شكل فاجنر في هذه
المعادله هل ستكون فاجنر موجوده ام لا
وساطه الرئيس البيلاروسي صيد لوكاشينكا هي
نجحت نوعا ما ولكن ما تم التثبيت هذا
النجاح وكل شيء ممكن ان يتغير نحو اسوا من
جديد خلال ساعات مقبله لانه انا متاكد انه
يوجد ناس فيه وزاره الدفاع لا يريدون ان
يتفقوا الان مع السيد
ويريدون القضاء على هذه الشركه وعلى
استقلاليتها ومن وجهه نظر الدوله لديهم حق
في ان يطالبوا بهذا الشيء هذه
المصالحه هي لحتى الان هشه جدا على فكره
امبارح امس مساء متاخرا ايضا كانت هناك
محاولات من قبل اداره الرئيس حتى لايجاد
حلول ومن ضمن هذه المحاولات كان في مقترح
انه ان يتم
انه تم اختراق
حساب سيد بريكوزن وهذه هي تصريحات مزيفه
وخلاص ولكن بعد ما توصل
تواصلت الاطراف لمثل هذه الاتفاق وحتى
وزاره الدفاع صرح حتى هذا الشيء من جديد
قد تراجع من ناحيته فهو اكيد سينتظر الان
ضمانات لا له
وهذا ما تحدثت عنه الرئاسه بيلاروسيه هذا
ما تحدثت عنه
الرئاسه البيلاروسيه ولكن ايضا ذهبنا
الوقت اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا من موسكو
الينا المستشاره السياسيه في مركز
الدراسات الدوليه
انطلقت فاقنر نحو الحدود الروسيه اساسا لم
تكن بعيده عنها وعبرت بعد دقائق عبرت
معبره بوغايفكا الحدوديه وامام المشهد رفض
180 عنصرا من حرس الحدود قتالفاجنر قوه
على الفور مدينه استراتيجيه وتمثل مفترق
طرق امداد الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا لكنها
تحمل رمزيه تاريخيه ايضا في هذا البيت
مشاهدينا البيت الصغير في مدينه روستوف
تاسست فاجنر عام 2014 والهدف هو دعم
انفصاليين ضد اوكرانيا بشكل غير رسمي وهنا
ايضا اسس
علاقات قويه مع القاده العسكريين بحلول
الصباح اليوم دخلت قوات فاجنر مدينه
روستوف مره اخرى دون اطلاق اي رصاصه يقول
بروجوجن القوات الروسيه
اختلطتار وتقاسم الشارع نفسه حتى الروس
اختلطت عليهم الامور
قافله لقوه فاجنر في وسط مدينه روستو لقد
تحدثت قبل قليل مع احد المقاتلين
قال لي انهم هنا في نزهه ثم سالته ان كانت
تابعا لفاجنر فاشار براسه مؤكدا ذلك
ومن العاصمه الدنماركيه من كوبنهاجن ينضم
الينا الصحفي المتخصص في الشان الروسي
السامر الياس اذا كانت هناك الكثير من
المداولات الغربيه حول الوضع الداخلي
الروسي قبل ان تاتي الاخبار الان من
بيلاروسيا والتفاصيل بان بروجوجان التراجع
عن خطواته نحو موسكو ولكن بكل الاحوال
كانت بيلاروسيا ايضا قالت ان ريغوشن قدم
هديه بهذا التمرد للغرب كيف كانت تنظر
الدول الغربيه لهذه الخطوات من قبل
بريكوجن وكيف كانت تنظر لاستغلالها
تحيه طيبه اعتقد بان الجانب الغربي مستفيد
اساسي من هذه من حركه التمرد هذه اي ضعف
في الجيش الروسي وايضا في
امكانيه صد الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يصب
في مصلحه اوكرانيا وفي مصلحه البلدان
الغربيه التي تريد تراجع الجيش الروسي
واجبار الرئيس فلاديم مربوطين على الجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات وتقديم بعض التنازلات
في العمليه التفاوضيه لايجاد تسويه في
اشياء الاوكراني لكنها بطبيعه الحال لا
تريد انتصار كامل للرئيس بلادين روبوتون
ولا تريد انهزاما كاملا له
[موسيقى]
حركه التمرد هذه تخدم اوكرانيا وحركه
التمرد هذه تثبت بان قبضه روسيا قبضه
بوتين على الحكم في روسيا ليست مطلقه
وربما تؤدي الى تراجع كبير في شعبيه
الرئيس بلادي مربوطين على ابواب الانت
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله هذا على
الاقل ما تراهن عليه الاطراف الغربيه
بانها يمكن ان تجد شخصيه اقل اكثر قدره
على التفاوض مع الجانب الغربي بطبيعه
الحال هناك مخاوف من ان شخصيه قوميه
متشدده قد تصعد الى سده الحكم في روسيا في
عام 2024 في حال انهار بوتين وخسر خساره
كبيره فيه هذه المعركه او في حال انتصرت
شخصيه مثل شخصيه
الذي يتصف بانه شخصيه قوميه متشدده لا
يمكن التفاهم معه بشكل او باخر رغم ان
حدود السياسيه لم تكن كبيره بكل الاحوال
نظرا لماضيه الاجرامي نظرا لطبيعته ونظرا
للمهمات التي تم انكالها له من قبل الرئيس
الذي مربوط والكرملين وبعض رجال الاعمال
النافذين في روسيا نعم نظرا الى انك انه
كان يمثل تهديدا اكبر للجنرال ات الروس
وكان يتحدث بكل ايجابيه عن الرئيس بوتين
ولكن من هذه النقطه مما حدث في الاربعه
والعشرين ساعه الماضيه يعني
التحرك الداخلي الروسي وهذه الازمه التي
نجمت عن التمرد لو وصل الامر الى زعزعه
النظام في روسيا ما الذي يريده الغرب بعد
من اوكرانيا ومن حربها ومن مدها بالسلاح
ان تكون روسيا مساندا للصين في هذه الحرب
ايضا تريد ربما الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والغرب من هذه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا تحسين اوضاع هناك بعض
اللوبيات المستفيده من هذه الحرب بالتاكيد
في داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
زادت انتاج الغاز الطبيعي والنفط وتصدير
باسعار مرتفعه الى اوروبا عزلت روسيا
اقتصاديا عن اوروبا واعادت اللحمه الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي بعدما كان على ابواب
الانهيار في عام 2021 اثراء الانسحاب
المفاجئ وغير والذي لم تخبر به حلفائها من
قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وترك
الحلفاء الاوروبيين في افغانستان امام
طالبان شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا اصحتي
المتخصص في الشان الروسي السامر الياس من
كوبنهاجن اذا مشاهدينا بهذا تكون هي
الساعه قد وصل فيها
الطرفان فاغنر براغوشن والرئيس الروسي
بلادي
بالوساطه مع بيلاروسيا الى قرار تراجع
قوات فاجنر عن الدخول الى مركز العاصمه
موسكو التراجع الى مراكزها اذا وذلك
بواساطه بيلاروسيه قدمت من خلالها
الضمانات
اذا التغطيه مستمره مع العربيه ولكن
يكملها معكم الزميل طاهر بركه
[موسيقى]